الى تركيا الان كلجدار اوغلو يرفض رفع
رايه الاستسلام في مواجهه خصمه اللدود
اردوغان مرشح المعارضه يبحث عن اي وسيله
تساعده على المنافسه حتى وان اقتضى الامر
التحالف مع حزبين بتوجهين متناقضين الرجل
خلق جدلا واسعا من خلال حصوله على تاييد
حزبين يقفان على طرفي النقيض الحزب الاول
هو حزب النصر اليميني المتطرف والمناهض
للاجئين اما الحزب الثاني فهو الشعوب
الديمقراطي الكردي والذي اعلن رسميا انه
سيصوت ضد اردوغان
ليس خيارا لنا ابدا الخيار الوحيد هو
استبداله والسلطه التي يمثلها لذلك نؤكد
مره اخرى انه من المهم للغايه وهي اولويه
بالنسبه لنا الاعتراف بتوقعات ورغبه
الاكراد والشعب والمجتمع التركي ككل من
اجل الديمقراطيه والقانون والعداله
والمساواه والحريه وارادتهم الديمقراطيه
في صناديق الاقتراع
تحالفان متناقضان اذا ابرهما ابرمهما
الذي نجحا الى حد ما في تعويض تحالف سنان
اوغان المرشح الرئاسي السابق مع اردوغان
لكن التهديد الذي يواجهه كلجد روغلو بعد
تحالفاته الاخيره هو امكانيه خساره اصوات
ناخبين مؤيدين له يرفضون توجهات الكتل
المتحالفه الاكثر من ذلك فان هذه
التوافقات قد تضعف تماسك تحالف المعارضه
اصلا الذي يمثله كما قد تضرب مصداقيه
الرجل السياسيه فالقاعده الانتخابيه
المحتمله
لا تجمعها مواقف سياسيه متشابهه بقدر ما
تجمعها المصالح الانتخابيه
الاكراد والخشيه من فوز اردوغان وسط تصاعد
النبره القوميه قبيل جوله الاعاده في
الانتخابات التركيه واحتماليه فوز اردوغان
الذي اثار قلقا في صفوف الاكراد خوفا من
تصعيد عسكري الاحزاب المواليه للاكراد
تؤكد دعمها للمعارضه التركيه لكنهم لم
يذكروا بالاسم
النظام الغريب الذي اسسه اردوغان وشركائه
سبب المشاكل المجتمعيه التي نعاني منها ما
سيتم تصويت عليه في الثامن والعشرين من
مايو هو ماده امكانيه استمرار هذا النظام
الغريب من عدمه
تحول في المواقف في سنواته الاولى من
السلطه منح اردوغان المزيد من الحقوق
للاكراد والغى القيود المفروضه على
استخدام اللغه الكرديه عام 2015 وبعد
انهيار وقف اطلاق النار غير اردوغان مساره
السياسي
وشنت السلطات التركيه حمله قمع ادت الى
اعتقال الالاف من الاكراد
هذا وقد تطرح بعض التساؤلات ايضا حول شكل
الحكومه التركيه بعد كل هذه التحالفات
المتناقضه في حال فوزو طبعا فالاعرفوا
السياسيه تقتضي تسليم الرئيس لبعض المناصب
الحكوميه لاعضاء من الاحزاب والكتل
السياسيه التي قامت بتاييده في عمليه
التصويت وسيكون من الصعب تشكيل حكومه تضم
اعضاء بتوجهات متناقضه وحتى في حال حدوث
ذلك فانها ستكون حكومه هشه وغير متماسكه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات